you were in San Francisco yesterday at
the NFL shop right and I'm told that you
went shopping what did you buy at the
NFL shop
well I always want I'm in a partnership
with Visa so my brother he took the
spotlight in my last commercial yeah
very funny all the way yeah so he wanted
to give me the spotlight in this in this
commercial so we went to NFL shop and we
went shopping for you you went shopping
for me at our little shop yes what's so
nice of you and I'm sure I'm told that
you guys shot something while you were
there as this this is the brook the
spotlight my brother wanted to give me
give me back for the visa so let's check
it out let's take a look are you good to
go yeah I think we've got something for
everyone you got mom cover yep
thank you visa checkout oh yo Coenen
we're gonna see him tomorrow we gotta
bring him something oh yeah can I get
one of those not crying for the--
Popeyes
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
very nice did you feel you've paid for
this with your Visa card did you I mean
I did we partnered together so it's from
both of us okay
that's that's very nice of you I'll
cherish this forever
this proves that I know Rob Gronkowski
I'm told that you brought something
special for someone in our audience is
that true yes that's true it's gonna
something very special for football fans
and we have two tickets to the Super
Bowl game this Sunday it's not just two
tickets to the Super Bowl this is gonna
cover is this gonna cover like airfare
and airfare hotel and I don't know about
the party hopefully it does too if you
go out how are you gonna decide how are
you gonna Rob how are you gonna pick who
gets the take you're just going to go up
in the audience right now and give the
tickets away is I what you're gonna do
yes
representing oh yes always
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
there yeah that was a shocker he picked
someone wearing a Patriots Jersey
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]